if you donate speaking of donating
25,000 to $1,000,000 to a brand-new
Texas nonprofit you can meet with Donald
Trump based on events advertised by
Donald Trump sons Eric and Donald Jr the
Center for Public Integrity is reporting
that by donating to a brand-spankin'-new
texas nonprofit the directors of which
are Don jr. Eric Trump and two other
individuals named Gentry beech and Tom
Hicks jr. you can get access to Donald
Trump during inauguration weekend in
Washington DC Beach and Hicks are
reportedly close friends of Donald Trump
jr. both have helped to raise millions
upon millions of dollars for Donald
Trump's campaign what are the prizes
well if you are a million dollar donor
you get a quote private reception and
photo opportunity for 16 guests with
president Donald J Trump we have the
entire document
check out the names of the donation
levels let's go through this document
pad and just show people what it is
opening day president Donald Trump
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah they've created
a hashtag called opening day 45 of
course Trump as the 45th President of
the United States and this is where it
starts to get oo first the attire
camouflage and cufflinks will be the
attire for this major major a donor
event let's go to the next piece of this
flyer the bald eagle donation level is a
million dollars and as I mentioned that
gets you a meeting with 16 you and 15 of
your closest friends can meet Donald J
Trump
check out the names of the other
donation levels the $500,000 level is
the grizzly bear you can't write this
stuff although they did and wrote it
down on this piece of paper at the 250
thousand dollar level you're considered
an elk for this event and then the last
page of this opening day event a marlin
level designee comes in at the hundred
thousand dollar level if you can donate
fifty K you were called a rainbow trout
and $25,000 will get you a wild turkey
designation now the the paragraph on
this last page at the bottom right
all net pros
from opening day will be donated to
conservation charities super vague as
you might remember Donald Trump jr. once
threw a conservation charity had the
opportunity to kill an elephant which he
clearly seemed to enjoy very very much
and there are so many problems with this
obviously you've got a legal entity
created out of thin air suddenly they're
raising million-dollar contributions
with the vague goal of it's for
conservation and it's clearly all a ruse
pat for selling access to the president
this is actually a good deal though
because 25,000 to 1 million dollars to
get your picture taken with Donald Trump
yeah I mean he would charge people tens
of thousands of dollars for Trump
University and they only got to take a
picture with a cardboard cutout yeah no
you if you compare it this is actually
quite a good value and it's not the
first time that this type of thing has
been causing problems for the Trump
family they recently were criticized for
appearing to sell access to Ivanka Trump
the family canceled an auction for
coffee with Trump's daughter Ivanka
Trump last week ethics experts looked at
it and they said you know this is this
is kind of ethically questionable
this is globalist I'm sorry every time I
say globalist I have to say globalist
like Alex Jones globalist oligarchs in
action this is King kleptocrat in chief
and at this point nothing really
surprises me like if I heard that they
started selling off art from the White
House just Rachel taking it right off
the walls and putting it up on eBay to
get money for the Trump foundation I'd
say yeah it's insane but I wouldn't
actually be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised either but I'm just wondering
what type of precedent this is going to
set yo the Obama administration
prohibited this and the only other time
I think I've seen this is when Podesta's
brother was on the charity buzz website
as well next to Ivanka so it's it's
gonna set off a strange okay you're
making a good point
but we have to be fair Democrats did do
this stuff also like if you donated a
million bucks due to you know the full
slate of Democratic candidates you would
end up getting a call from someone
saying you've been invited to the White
House and you'll be able to get a
picture
with Obama with the Obamas that type of
thing but it wasn't so blatant that's
what really is stunning about the Trump
people right usually when we talk about
selling access it's done on a phone call
or a back room somewhere in a cage for a
campaign contribution this is just done
out on the open on inauguration day
let's wildly hypocritical as well
because this is exactly what he was
criticizing Hillary Clinton and the
Clinton Foundation for doing it and now
he is blatantly doing oh please yes
Trump criticized Hillary for being The
Wall Streeter and then he has three
Goldman Sachs people working as advisers
and or ready to be on his cabinet he
said he was going to drain the swamp and
he's filling it with a fire hose but we
don't need to worry guys this has
nothing to do with anyone's private
email server so there's no need to worry
there's no need for an investigation
everything's just all absolutely fine
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s